some say that a movie gets made three
times once when it's written again when
it's shot and finally when it's edited
but sometimes it feels like we overvalue
the first two steps and undervalue the
last one in film criticism we seem to
focus more on the writers and directors
and we especially love it when one
person does both but that still leaves
out one-third of the story and this
phenomenon is nothing new editors
weren't even given credit for their work
in early silent films back then people
saw cunning film as a menial job that
required no creativity as a result it
was labeled as a job suitable for women
and by extension not worth mentioning
but as filmmaking grew more
sophisticated editing quickly became a
crucial part of the creative process
while still remaining largely overlooked
and perhaps the most important of them
all is the legendary Dede Allen Bonnie
and Clyde is one of the most important
movies of all time that involved many
influential filmmakers like Arthur Penn
Warren Beatty and Francois Truffaut but
some film analysis overlooks editors
like Dede Allen it is not an
overstatement to say that her editing
changed films forever and that's why she
became the first editor in film history
to be credited with her own title card
for her work on Bonnie and Clyde so
let's dive into the work of Dede Allen
and see what it shows us about the
gendered history of Hollywood film
editing and who really makes the movie
to really understand how Allen upended
film language we have to look at the
generation of film editors who came
before her in 1938 film editor Margaret
Booth wrote the cutter an essay about
the role of a film atom she describes
the techniques she learned that we now
take for granted things like
establishing shots using close-ups to
stress an emotional moment and cutting
to move smoothly through different shots
she established an artistry to film
editing it was no longer just assembling
film but finding the rhythm of a scene
in her words cutting at its best
produces a film flowing so smoothly that
the audience thinks only of the
entertainment and gives no thought to
the mechanics that went to create it
much of her early work in film was
uncredited and she notes that apart from
editing filmmaking was a masculine
affair she even implies this insight in
her word choice on the first page she
refers to an editor as he or she but a
director as only he
she collaborated with DW Griffith and
other influential early directors whose
films created the playbook by which all
other editors works the more invisible
the editor the better long shot to shot
single single
there was a almost a formulaic way of
presenting films that style remains the
exclusive method of film editing in
Hollywood until Dede Allen upended at
all from the start of her career Allen
couldn't help but break rules she got
her start editing television commercials
a medium that naturally disobeyed
Hollywood standards commercials needed
to communicate a lot of information in a
short period of time so they favored
striking fast paced cutting over the
slower paced Hollywood style and she
didn't shy away from these techniques
when she transitions to editing feature
films Allen's in-your-face and rhythmic
style sent shockwaves throughout the
industry
she made a name for herself by turning
Hollywood editing tropes on their head
rather than abiding by the industry
standard of using a dissolve to signal
the passage of time I would prefer to do
the exact opposite instead she would cut
harshly from one moment to another at
the start of her career she defaulted to
Hollywood norms but in the 1960s she
experimented with using a harsh cut to
imply the passage of time instead of a
dissolve by the 70s her cuts grew more
daring and in this scene she jumps to
later moments in the night and by the
80s her cuts jumps to new days entirely
this technique puts the editor in the
forefront and calls attention to the
cuts but instead of disrupting the film
it lends a rhythm to these scenes and it
gives more information to the viewer in
a shorter period of time soon after her
films received acclaim editors
throughout the industry mimicked Allen's
signature fast paced editing and her
techniques became commonplace another
example of an editing technique that she
made standard was pre lapping audio from
the next scene into the scene preceding
[Music]
these are techniques so widely used now
it almost seems mundane but at the time
it was another example of her
breaking style at the start of Serpico
she uses it to great effect we hear the
siren the rhythmic beating of the
windshield and the labored breathing
before we even see a character on screen
she communicated the tense tone of the
film immediately and it works this
opening challenge is several established
editing conventions he said you always
start with a long shot then you move in
to an over shoulder or a group shot and
he said and you never changed that order
and somehow or other I was breaking
constantly instead of opening on a wide
shot of the city or even a medium shot
of the car Allen chose to open the film
on a close-up of Al Pacino's bleeding
face she replaced a spatial establishing
shot with a tonal establishing shot and
that combined with the pre lapping
sounds Prime's the audience for the
tense and unsettling tone of the film
its innovations like hers that have
become so ingrained in film language
that we still see her influence
everywhere Allen's preference to start a
scene even a film on a close-up of a
character reveals something very
important about her style her focus on
performance she was an actor's editor
and often kept in mistakes as long as
they gave authenticity to the scene okay
while her editing was no doubt in her
face and never sacrificed the moments
the camera captured we can see her
ability to capture the moment in the
famous Attica scene in dog day afternoon
the editing his stylistic and the cuts
speed up overtime but she still takes
the time to hold on Pacino as he paces
nervously and considers his situation or
to cut back to his partners nervous look
inside the bank considering the scale of
this scene with interiors exteriors
several characters and even aerial shots
it would have been no surprise if it had
to sacrifice these intimate moments but
Allen's care to build naturally and
focus on character rather than spectacle
makes it such an electric moment these
innovations are why she became the first
editor woman or man to receive an
opening title card exclusively for her
embodying Clyde in a position that
originally left the female editor
invisible her style not only enhanced
visual storytelling but it clearly shows
the influence and editor has on the
final film
by the 1980s TV Allen's talent became
well-established and later in her career
she had a role in more than just
post-production while editing for The
Breakfast Club writer director John
Hughes referred to her as his film
teacher she would regularly contribute
during filming and she was there in
person with all her equipment she would
walk onto the set and tell John if there
was a shot or an angle she could already
see when she would cut together what we
were doing that she would need you can
see her influence by comparing shot
coverage in the Breakfast Club with
Hughes his previous film sixteen Candles
for example both films had a weird girl
listening in on the main conversation
but in sixteen Candles she's only filmed
in the wide shot and because of that
limitation her performance doesn't
really land in her scene with the better
shot coverage in the Breakfast Club Dede
Allen had much more to work with like
her previous work The Breakfast Club is
a feat in editing Allen cuts between up
to six characters at once and it never
feels confusing or unnatural this film
proves how an editor can make or break a
film and makes us realize that a film's
vision comes from more than the writer
director she had a say in how it was
shot and according to Hughes she changed
the way he cut pictures forever the
editor he said is the single most
underrated person in the whole business
but collaboration is not always that
smooth for some first-time male
directors their ego can become a problem
I was doing my first movie only thing I
knew is I wanted a female editor because
I just felt a female editor would be
more nurturing to the movie and to me
they wouldn't be trying to shove their
agenda or win their battles with me
Tarantino had difficulty compromising
with his editor in his early films the
date scene in Pulp Fiction was
originally much longer but editor Sally
manky fought hard to trim it down
constantly going back and forth with him
we do that for eight months so intense I
see him more than my husband but like
other great female editors Sally had be
passionate and raw talent to convince
her director to change the film
to convince them let me try it the other
way
very awfully if you watch the deleted
scenes at the diner and imagine
Tarantino's original even longer scene
it's pretty clear that Sally's input
saved it after her tragic death in 2010
Tarantino called her his only truly
genuine collaborator and one can only
imagine how much stronger the pacing of
his post inglorious basterds films would
have been if Sally was there to make
them with him Tarantino was one of the
countless male directors who owe their
success in part to a brilliant female
editor the idea that a singular historic
female director is the sole visionary
for a film comes into question when
considering female editors like Sally
Menke Margaret Booth and Dede Allen
these women had a lot more creative
control than most people are aware of
[Music]
and throughout film history the editor
was the only feminine point-of-view
available to the director margaret booth
felt that directors often preferred her
over a man of equal ability and
experience because the director could
get her unique perspective as a woman
even 100 years ago female film editors
had a say in how movies got made the
very nature of an editor's work dooms
the profession to be constantly
underappreciated the majority of the
work takes place alone in a dark room
and it's unfortunate that this
environment was the only one that a
woman how to say far removed from every
other aspect of filmmaking there's a
cruel irony to the fact that an editor
is successful if her work is invisible
in the final product and to filmmaking
legends like Alan goes so
underappreciated one can't help but
wonder what other voices we miss when we
say a film was made by a singular writer
director so the next time you watch a
Scorsese film or a Tarantino film ask
yourself
DeeDee Allen's work into the work of
countless other women in film often
remains invisible to the average
moviegoer especially when you only focus
on who's producing writing and directing
blockbuster films meanwhile women are
dominating other less high-profile parts
of the film industry like documentary
filmmaking four out of the five
oscar-nominated films for Best
Documentary in 2020 had female directors
or co directors documentary films
featuring legendary editors writers and
producers that like Dede Allen are often
overlooked but with curiosity streams
newly expanded library there are
thousands of documentary titles that
will have you in awe of the nonfiction
genre like the history of food a
critically acclaimed documentary about
the science history and cultural impact
of food over time which is produced and
co-written and directed by Sarah Venable
Byrnes
what better way to spend your quarantine
two days than to expand your mind and
there's more to curiosity Stream has
partnered with nebula the creator own
streaming service that I actually helped
build along with a bunch of other
creators you know and love there we're
posting all of our content ad-free as
well as creating nebula originals like
the ongoing series working titles it's a
series analyzing TV title sequences with
episodes by patrick h willem is just
right and yours truly and nebula
subscriptions are automatically included
with an annual subscription to curiosity
stream go to curiosity stream comm slash
now you see it and enter the promo code
now you see it when prompted during the
signup process
thanks to curiosity stream for
sponsoring and thanks to you our patrons
for your support if you want to support
our work directly join our patreon for
exclusive benefits thanks for watching